doest joke in the style of Sal vulcano I
went to the doctor the other day and he
told me to stop Matt
the boy on my own
he goes it's like a cat skills I went to
the doctor because I went to the I went
to the doctor the other day and he told
me to stop mastering I asked him why and
he said because I'm trying to examine
you
um
so he so they took a joke that's already
been done a million times then I put do
a joke in style of Christmas Stefano I
hate doing laundry every time I'm
folding clothes I feel like I'm playing
a game of Tetris with my underwear and
let me tell you trying to fit a thong in
my boxers is like trying to fit a square
peg into a round hole it just doesn't
work folks
foreign